this big zipper museum do Brendon my
name is Deb it's my little brother
Hudson he's got a wrestling practice
here in Lynchburg Virginia my brother
just signed to wrestle at UVA on
Wednesday all right super proud of him
Wow I can't wait you know you know from
the to do well there but maybe think
with debate club for you guys which were
your better years your high school years
your college years let us know gangrene
bursitis congrats you're an UVA must be
a smart kiddin right
yeah good team to bro yeah that's
beautiful that man can do all of it hell
yeah it was high school college years my
best years are right now son yeah right
now not even close high school you're
trying to figure things out I got
injured my senior year dreams were
shattered college and an afro I got
[ __ ] over by my african-american coach
cuz I was white I don't know dreams were
shattered I kept on dreaming though you
know it's a dream yeah but you've always
been you've always you just read you
read ream bore you reshape the dream
every time I think high school really I
don't fit you you were cool in high
school I wasn't cool but I was so
nervous dude yeah I used to flex my butt
when I would walk sometimes that make
sense way of a dumb I was so nervous
dude I was yeah I don't know I was
something was wrong with me and then
college Oh College was really pretty
rough call Jesse that part was Oh the
first part was part of someone was good
everything was [ __ ] good bra I know
it wasn't though bro some what stuff man
yes it was tough but I think I always
focus on the tough part so the things
that were good dude I used to get high
and [ __ ] go I go I would get high in
people's cars in my neighborhood I was
sneaking and sitting there back at her
car and get high in college and then in
high school and then one time I fell
asleep in this lady's car and she
[ __ ] took me to work in the morning I
should even know I was in the very back
it's your run a post office so I got
like two miles and that's when I kind of
cut the quit smoking weed I was I'm
[ __ ] this just you athletic bro I had
a good childhood Bhangra playing sports
had friends you know we just you know
which ones you like better though
between high score college I don't know
they're both good man I didn't have like
you know I'd have terrible times my seat
chair with dreams shadow just sports you
know
yeah just Fred's great friends great
friends high school don't talk to him
anymore great friends in college you
know I'm gonna go high school because
I'm a I had so many friends then and it
was just I really I did better when I
was around more people and once I got
into college I think I was just around
less people it just you know it's a
little bit more yourself you can isolate
more and so once I once I got into that
vein man I was great high school I feel
like it's really it's exciting because
everyone everyone you know yeah no one's
really a loser yet cuz they you know
they you know they're trying to figure
out so everybody thinks they're gonna
make it so you're all like yeah let's do
it
yeah they're like three of you make it I
mean everybody knows I mean everybody
makes it everybody just makes it depends
what you define on making it yeah yeah
what do you guys think I said the cult
let's hit the culture corner
high school wall Dave dog high school
you went to college dad was College oh
yeah I mean I just dropped out after two
and a half years mmm but I wanted to
stick it out home for another year I
don't stand up man yeah that [ __ ] that's
that real drug bro stand up no the class
when you doing that [ __ ] huh
can it wait a year and having it the
degree though waiting the your dad's to
stop doing stand-up after you started
doing it it's [ __ ] hard bro be tough
yeah what about online have you thought
about finish man they can never take it
away from you bro what'd you get that
agree unless he's telling my mom dawg
you deserve it you should get it for
yourself man I just think he should you
can still get it serve it but you can
doesn't mean drop down bro you learn
that [ __ ] dude get off our land buddy
joint Phoenix online or some [ __ ]
dude I heard us even Harvard I think
pretty easy to join these days online
yeah really a Nicki Minaj part of it any
school Nicki Minaj [ __ ] going to but
I said ass class I think that yeah man
you should get it get it slow and take a
little time but you should get it it
took me about 11 years man
yeah tell my mom that fancy looking like
some 9 years she got one slow yeah but
then she wouldn't got the Masters in the
doctor like immediately uh-oh work smart
not to have it bruh you deserve to have
it just to have it just to have it they
can never they can never take it away
from you or anything you don't get it
for free this ain't the [ __ ] Saint
Bernie Sanders University if he deserves
end of a heart attack like that old [ __ ]
you know I'm saying can you believe that
one day if everything keeps just getting
giving everything it's just can be like
oh and you everybody at college should
get a degree that's gonna be a thing
when they can you believe that crazy
everybody's gonna have a degree yeah
who's gonna care can't you get your
bachelor's in four years like a regular
student or were you fifteen seventeen
years like these guys I did Community
College for two years transferred out
and took three years cuz us he was weird
with their prerequisites they made me
take everything again why did you go to
JUCO did you had bad grades no I don't
want to spend all the money on a
university for the first two years
where'd you go huh well JUCO I ended up
going to Evergreen Valley College in San
Jose not familiar with not a great
school shut up bark isn't the bark with
third tree name what's their name I
don't even know if they don't have a
team I think I think it's just like a
bunch of like 24-year old like Asian
dudes like hey I did it like tattoos
like I did my mom do I don't know about
giucose from last chance you you feel me
gang it looks like a real [ __ ] show yeah
looks like prison but with football also
known as the movie The Longest Yard that
Joey Diaz was in yeah Long's yard yeah
yeah all right I think you should go
back to college and Eric
that the question which this guy's
that's what you guys like better high
school was the [ __ ] from high school or
college high school because I think
there's just exciting it's exciting so
I'm having sex if you're a normal kid
like sixteen girl you're sneaking around
for son trying drugs a lot of old late
molest you molesters start [ __ ]
looking over at you bruh you know and
you get to fend them off though it's
like a really strong it's like a friend
of mine yeah it's a double dragon okay
double dragon hell yeah yeah gang [ __ ]
what else we got
[Music]